partout
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur l'apple c'était
vraiment le laboratoire volant qui
montrait que non seulement on pouvait
s'alimenter au solaire non plus on
pouvait être extrêmement efficients sur
le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il est en état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
le premier ministre français sous
pression edouard philippe travaille
activement un plan de déconfinement pour
le pays sa copie doit être présenté la
semaine prochaine
le ministre de la santé lui espère
atteindre une production d'au moins 500
mille tests par semaine
11 mai prochain la pression elle diminue
dans les hôpitaux au moins de 5000
personnes en réanimation et un bilan de
plus de 22 mille cinq cents morts ce
soir
plus de cent vingt mille morts en europe
dont les trois quarts des décès en
france en espagne en italie et au
royaume uni
plusieurs pays se préparent également
aux déconfinement chacun avec ses
propres règles
l' oms a néanmoins prévenu la pandémie
est loin d'être terminée
et alors que l'épidémie a tué près de
deux cent mille personnes dans le monde
et en a infecté plus de 2 millions la
syrie elle n'aurait officiellement que
très peu de cas 3 morts et une
quarantaine de malades
un bilan qui pourrait être beaucoup plus
lourd en cas d'aggravation pour ce pays
toujours sous le coup de sanctions
internationales
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir le gouvernement
français à pied d'oeuvre pour tenter
d'élaborer un plan de sortie plusieurs
réunions de travail ce week-end pour
edouard philippe premier ministre sous
pression distribution de masques test de
dépistage rentrée des classes autant de
sujets prioritaires pour le gouvernement
ce matin le ministre de la santé s'est
fixé pour objectif la production de 500
à 700 mille masques par semaine à partir
du 11 mai olivier ferrand était en
déplacement dans un laboratoire
biologique de seine-saint-denis écoutez
j'ai vu là une dynamique incroyable un
vestiaire qui a été transformé en
l'espace de quelques jours en une
plateforme de test pcr la capacité
d'aller recruter des biologistes des
techniciens de laboratoire des gens pour
faire des prélèvements
ils ont réalisé l'exploit d'être capable
à la fois de dépister dans les ehpad de
dépister les malades qui devait l'être
mais également de créer ce qu'on appelle
des drive tests c'est à dire qu'ils
mettent à proximité généralement de leur
laboratoire
des équipes mobiles à l'extérieur pour
faire des prélèvements c'est ainsi que
nous allons fonctionner dans les
prochaines semaines pour faire face à
l'épidémie
avec cet objectif que je rappelle qui
est de réaliser au moins 500 700 mille
tests par semaine à partir du moment où
nous lèverons progressivement le
confinement conséquences de la pénurie
des masques médicaux en france depuis le
début de cette crise les médecins croule
sous les sollicitations d'individus ou
d'entreprises qui veulent leur vendre
leurs marchandises parfois à des prix
exorbitants un trafic dénoncé par les
médecins eux-mêmes d'autant que la
provenance et la qualité de ces produits
n'est pas forcément la garantie voyez ce
qu'en dit jean mus paul hamon il est
médecin généraliste et président de la
fédération des médecins de france
la morale de l'histoire c'est que il
faudra être autosuffisant pour une
production française
que ce soit en masse mais que ce soit
également plaît parce que je pense qu'on
va mettre un petit peu de temps je pense
que d'ici le 11 mai les laboratoires
sont en capacité de faire les 500000
thèse que que demande le ministre et je
pense que là pour éviter la deuxième
vague
avec des tests avec des masques en
confinant les gens contaminés et en
cernant les personnes contacts je pense
qu'on sera en mesure de de contenir une
deuxième bague est de contenir
l'épidémie le bilan des décès en france
qui a dépassé les 22 mille cinq cents
morts il y a eu 3 169 décès ces
dernières 24 heures les services de
réanimation commence à ne plus être sous
tension le nombre d'hospitalisations en
réanimation est repassé sous la barre
normal des 5000 hier et sur le plan
économique l'état a doublé également
hier son plan d'urgence qui est passé de
45 à 100 milliards d'euros
la compagnie air france va recevoir 7
milliards d'euros sous la forme de prêts
5 milliards d'euros promis également
groupe automobile renault le secteur de
la restauration à l'arrêt depuis le 15
mars devra lui attendre la fin mai pour
être fixé sur son sort
par contre pas de nationalisation à
l'ordre du jour
voyez ce qu'en dit henri sterdyniak il
est économiste cas c'est une solution
qui va s'imposer on a une entreprise qui
est en très grande difficulté on a une
entreprise qui va avoir beaucoup de mal
dans les années à venir parce que le
transport aérien va sans doute connaître
un extrêmement important et donc essayé
on voit mal comment de telles
entreprises pourront subsister dans le
secteur privé on va mal comment air
france pourra être rentable dans les
années à venir sachant que d'un côté il
y aura moins de passagers et de l'autre
on demande à air france de faire un
effort important pour réduire ça ça va
c'est les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre tout ça fait que ça sera un
secteur en perte dans les années à venir
faut pas se faire d'illusions et depuis
le 17 mars dernier à les marchés ont
parfois dû fermer
et maraîchers ont dû trouver d'autres
solutions pour continuer à vendre leurs
fruits et légumes
certains vous allez le voir ne manquent
pas d'imagination le reportage en
régions centre et signées renaud parquet
et pierre pissavy yvernault regarder
dans ce maraîchage bio du loiret les
habitudes ont changé
plus question devenir soi-même cueillir
les fruits et légumes dans la serre de
l'exploitation
aujourd'hui tout se fait grâce au
nouveau service
le drive les clients viennent désormais
chercher leurs achats en voiture grâce à
un procédé créé spécialement pour éviter
d'aller à l'encontre des mesures de
distanciation social un bon mari a
développé à l'outil informatique pour
que les gens puissent passer commande
sur internet
ensuite on réceptionne les commandes aux
récoltes à la place des gens et on
prépare les commandes et ils viennent
les chercher sur notre parking
le lendemain voir le surlendemain ben en
fait c'est comme un site marchand
il faut cliquer sur la quantité des
produits qu'ils souhaitent
ça leur ait dit une facture et ensuite
qui viennent payer sur place une fois
qu'ils récupèrent la commun pour
continuer son activité mylène chenaux a
dû s'adapter rapidement en quelques
jours il a fallu revoir les méthodes de
travail pour tenter d'éviter au maximum
les contacts
une tâche supplémentaire pour les
propriétaires niveau administratif faut
que la commande à elle passe par
différents statuts et un statut en cours
de préparation une fois qu'elle est
préparée
il faut envoyer un mail aux clients
comme quoi elle est prête et ensuite une
fois qu'ils sont venus la récupérer
informatiquement faut à nouveau m comme
quoi elle est livrée et payée
donc c'est un peu de saisie quant aux
clients leur habitude ont elles aussi
changer la récupération de la commande
se fait dorénavant sur le parking avec
la distance réglementaire de nouvelles
méthodes qui ne perturbe pas vraiment
les habitués à certains d'entre eux y
voient même un aspect positif
le gain de temps est bien
je vais plus me servir au niveau des
serres donc c'est beaucoup plus pratique
en fin de compte
parce que on commande la veille pour le
lendemain et c'est un gain de temps
finalement je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce système parce que bon ça protège
quand même contre locaux vides 19 et je
trouve que la mise en place et est
nécessaire
côté emploi un saisonniers venus même
renforcer l'équipe pour pouvoir répondre
correctement à la demande locale
si le confinement amener les
professionnels à s'adapter certains en
ont profité pour perfectionner leurs
méthodes de travail
l'europe comptabilise 120 mille décès à
ce jour et chaque pays se préparent
également au confinement pour ceux qui
l'avaient adopté bien sûr au
déconfinement pas au confinement
en belgique la première ministre a
annoncé les premières mesures de reprise
progressive les commerces et les écoles
rouvriront respectivement les 11 et 18
mai prochain comme en france le port du
masque lui sera obligatoire dans les
transports en commun à partir du 4 mai
pour tous les voyageurs de plus de 12
ans la première ministre qui a également
insisté sur le fait que la propagation
du virus a été je cite ralenti mais que
l' équilibre reste encore fragile fin de
citation en espagne le gouvernement lui
annoncer un léger rebond du nombre de
morts quotidiens avec 378 décès
concernant la situation sociale des
syndicats et des associations ont appelé
à une grève des loyers pour en guise de
solidarité avec toutes les personnes en
difficulté suite à cette crise sanitaire
les espagnols qui serait déjà plus de
quinze mille à avoir soutenu cet appel
aurélie chaumont et aurélie chamerois
pardon et quentin mauclair alors que les
espagnols placés au chômage partiel en
mars ne se sont toujours pas vu verser
leurs allocations chômage par l'état
beaucoup ne paient plus leur loyer
depuis le mois dernier
c'est le cas de bertha qui travaillait
dans l'hôtellerie avant la crise du
crédit
9 elle vient tout juste de retrouver un
emploi dans une résidence médicalisée
avec quel argent on va payer les loyers
en ce moment on reçoit déjà les factures
les factures de gaz d'électricité et il
faut les payer mais avec tous ces gens
qui n'ont plus de travail d'où va-t-on
sortir l'argent pour payer tous ces
frais de la maison le gaz l'électricité
l'eau et en plus le loyer
donc oui je soutiens la grève des loyers
en espagne un retard d'un mois de loyer
est suffisant pour que le propriétaire
puisque lancer une procédure d'expulsion
mais sous la pression des associations
de défense du droit au logement le
gouvernement espagnol a décrété un
moratoire sur les expulsions immobilière
jusqu'au 2 octobre prochain les
fournisseurs d'eau d'électricité et de
gaz ont également l'interdiction de
suspendre leurs services dans les
résidences principales des citoyens
toutes les expulsions sans solution de
relogement pour les personnes
vulnérables sont suspendues à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à six mois après
la fin de l'état d'urgence
personne ne peut être expulsée de son
domicile
tous les contrats de location en cours
qui sont sur le point d'expirer sont
automatiquement prolongé de six mois
une mesure qui dans la pratique signifie
qu'aucun locataires en espagne ayant un
contrat en cours ne pouvoir son loyer
augmenter au cours des six prochains
mois
l'exécutif propose aussi des micro
crédits publics à taux préférentiel est
remboursable sur 10 ans insuffisant
voire complètement inapproprié pour les
associations comme la plate forme anti
expulsions et de défense du droit au
logement qui demande l'annulation pure
et simple des loyers pour les personnes
sont revenus à la suite de la crise du
coc vite 19
la réalité c'est que seulement 10% des
familles qui en ont besoin vont pouvoir
accéder aux crédits de l'état et car les
critères sont tellement restrictif que
presque personne ne pourra les avoir et
en plus ce que l'état propose à ces
familles dans le besoin c'est de
s'endetter pour pouvoir payer le loyer
aux grands propriétaires et aux fonds
spéculatifs qui viennent spéculer en
espagne donc ce que nous demandons c'est
qu'il y ait une annulation de ces loyers
de la part de ses grands propriétaires
à barcelone par exemple le parc locatif
est détenue à 33% par des grands
propriétaires le gouvernement
travaillait également sur la création
d'un revenu minimal vitale 2 500 euros
par mois pour les plus démunis
un décret en ce sens doit être publié
très prochainement
en italie la levée des restrictions sera
l progressive sur quatre semaines le
quotidien il corriere della serra évoque
une reprise de certains chantiers à
partir du 4 mai vous le voyez à cette
même date le pays commencera une
campagne de tests sérologiques sur cent
cinquante mille personnes
quant aux bars et aux restaurants il
faudra attendre au moins le 18 mai
prochain
le quotidien qui précise toutefois que
ce programme reste bien sûr soumis à
l'évolution de la courbe des contagions
au royaume-uni pas de déconfinement en
vue pour l'instant plus de vingt mille
personnes sont décédées à ce jour dans
les hôpitaux
depuis le début de l'épidémie le premier
ministre boris johnson lui est toujours
en convalescence il s'est dit néanmoins
en pleine forme retour aux affaires
bientôt pour boris johnson dans ce
contexte compliqué londres négocie
toujours sa sortie de l'union européenne
la discussion sur la future relation
post-bts l'exit a été très critiquée par
le négociateur en chef de l'ue au michel
barnier il a accusé le royaume uni de
manqué d'engagement il faut dire qu'il
ne reste que deux sessions de
négociations d'ici au 30 juin
et c'est la date limite de prolongation
des négociations pour le brésil
une situation compliquée voyez l'analyse
de françois poulet mathis journalistes
et spécialistes des institutions
européennes pour prendre en compte quand
même une réalité c'est que cette
épidémie de coronavirus arrive au pire
moment des négociations à un moment où
on avait besoin d'une forte
disponibilité et cette disponibilité
n'est pas vraiment là je vous rappelle
que les deux négociateurs david frost et
michel barnier ont tous les deux étaient
touchés par le virus du gros navires us
dont condé face à deux positions de
principe qui pour l'instant n'évolue pas
c'est assez préoccupant parce que il ne
reste que deux sessions de négociations
d'ici le 30 juin et le 30 juin c'est la
date à laquelle normalement la date
limite à laquelle les britanniques
devront dire s'ils veulent prolonger ou
pas ces dépréciations
or ils ont très clairement fait savoir
qu'il ne voulait pas prolonger ces
négociations or pour les européens il
est pas question de se passer d'un
accord global qui est la seule condition
pour lequel les britanniques pourraient
conserver un accès au marché unique qui
je le rappelle est une condition
nécessaire pour éviter un véritable
arbre excite le ramadan un des puits a
débuté hier pour les musulmans du monde
entier des croyants qui vont devoir
rester confinés chez eux
pas de prières à la mosquée cette année
alors comment s'organise t-il dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire
nos équipes ont suivi une famille
pratiquante en algérie le récit est
signée grégoire douce et les images
l'opti à rabat et karim est benhamouda
réécoute à regarder la nuit tombée
synonyme d'interruption du jeûne à alger
comme dans le reste du monde les
musulmans entament le ramadan pour une
période d'un mois
une pratique qui consiste notamment à se
priver de nourriture entre le lever et
le coucher du soleil
cette année le contexte est particulier
couvre-feu oblige les prières
collectives sont suspendus une situation
compliquée qu'accepte tant bien que mal
fayçal s'éloigner drame endeuille aura
pas il y aura pas de la prière towers
surtout surtout de travailleurs c'est
bon pour nous c'est sacré pour les
musulmans tu vois je ramasse j'en ai
passé à passer parce que il y aura pas
de la prière
on va rester chez nous pour faire leurs
prières et tout le confirme on va
commencer à 17 heures on sait jamais
habitué à ça c'est à partir de 17h tu en
parles de tapis le droit de sortir
dehors
malika les pousses de fayçal est quant à
elle fataliste
habituellement c'est vrai que je passe
mon ramadan en france je suis venu on
visite ici à alger mais je le retrouve
coincé parce que ben y'a pas de vols
je ne peux pas me déplacer mais c'est
vrai qu'ici aussi le ramadan n'est pas
n'est pas comme d'habitude
il a un petit goût amer en matière un
confinement que la maman de malika vite
avec le désagréable sentiment de tourner
en rond
nous ne faisons rien après le repas on
est en stand by personnellement je dois
marcher puisque j'ai de l'arthrose
et comme je ne peux pas sortir je marche
sur le balcon
nous ne voulons pas ni les grands
l'année les enfants qui n'en peuvent
plus les pauvres
l'imam djelloul à jimmy tron de son côté
avec philosophie ce ramadan atypique
là chacun il est clair que le monde en
général et la nation musulmane avec ses
particularités et spécialement durant ce
mois de ramadhan sont touchés par cette
situation sanitaire
[Musique]
mais cela doit nous aider à être plus
croyants et plus respectueux de dieu
nous devons rester à la maison faire nos
prières et réciter le coran
de ce fait toutes nos maisons
deviendront des lieux de culte dans la
capitale algérienne
les horaires de couvre-feu ont été
assouplies par les autorités pour les
musulmans du monde entier le ramadan
prendra fin aux alentours du 23 mai
prochain alors que la pandémie a tué
près de deux cent mille personnes dans
le monde avec 2 millions de personnes
infectées la syrie
elle n'aurait officiellement que très
peu de cas 3 morts et une quarantaine de
malades
un bilan qui pourrait être beaucoup plus
lourd en cas d'aggravation pour ce pays
qui est toujours sous le coup de
sanctions internationales
clément hospital aux abords d'un banal
checkpoint dans le nord-ouest syrien
des virologues se glissent parmi les
militaires pour identifier plus
efficacement les citoyens atteints du
coc vite 19
la procédure est simple les médecins
prennent la température des occupants de
chaque voiture
de quoi rassurer cet automobiliste s'est
très bien notre syrie en a besoin
les patients soupçonné d'avoir contracté
le virus sont prises en charge dans les
hôpitaux de campagne déployés par
l'armée syrienne
les infrastructures ils sont vétustes et
leurs capacités sanitaires sont minimes
l' ong save the children estime que le
nord-est syrien dispose de moins de 30
lits dans des unités de soins intensifs
ainsi que des respirateurs pour adultes
et un seul pour enfants si le patient a
de la fièvre et de la toux
ils restent ici 48 heures nous
l'examinons en parallèle nous le
traitons par des moyens conventionnels
nous lui donnons à boire des anti fièvre
il signe à aucune amélioration nous
transférons le patient à l'hôpital
central de hama où de rome
l'ambition pour les prochains jours et
d'augmenter le nombre de cliniques
mobiles et de concevoir un site
d'accueil des personnes confinées la
pandémie a cependant permis de faire
cesser les bombardements entre la
turquie et l'armée syrienne dans la
région plusieurs médecins personnels
humanitaires confirment le respect du
cessez le feu
de quoi permettre aux syriens meurtri
par neuf ans de guerre de bénéficier
d'une meilleure aide humanitaire
pourquoi si peu de cas en syrie voyez
l'analyse de nabil lanta qui il est
médecin et directeur d'un hôpital dans
la ville d'alep
il ya d'abord le fait que la syrie est
presque coupé du monde il ya très peu de
d'étrangers qui viennent en syrie donc
la contagion qui se fait par les
voyageurs on se fait pas en ciel et
d'autre part les 42 cas qui ont été
déclarés en celi convient tous d'une
même région
et donc quand les autorités
voit qu'il ya deux ou trois personnes
contaminées qui viennent d'un village
ans est le village personne n'a plus le
droit de sortir et de rentrer dans son
visage ce qui fait que la propagation du
virus est vraiment stopper et dans ce
contexte de pandémie l'appel à l'aide
des populations indigènes d'amazonie
particulièrement vulnérables faute de
structures médicales
plusieurs chefs indigènes ont demandé
l'assistance de la communauté
internationale au cours d'une
visioconférence conjointe avec
l'organisation amnesty international
ils se disent délaissé par les
gouvernements de leurs pays respectifs
et ils craignent la disparition de leur
communauté
écoutez nous avons besoin de soutien
financier je me tourne donc vers vous
pour soutenir ma communauté
nous avons besoin d'être ravitaillée en
denrées d'alimentation basique en
produits d'hygiène en médicaments et
aussi en combustible pour pouvoir les
acheminer sans votre aide les peuples
indigènes du brésil ne pourront faire
face à cette terrible maladie
[Musique]
voyez les précisions de geert petter
brouchy les fondateurs de l'association
planète amazon ils sont malheureusement
touché par le virus
si vous parlez des peuples indigènes
d'amazonie
on est très inquiet pour le brésil mais
pas seulement si vous parlez des peuples
aussi indigènes des matif amérindiens
d'amérique du nord ont le peuple navajo
est actuellement décimé par la pandémie
donc là où il ya vraiment un état d'
alerte particulièrement dans les pays
amazoniens parce qu'ils sont comme vous
l'avez dit dans le reportage
complètement délaissés par leurs
dirigeants et hauts et au brésil la
situation est catastrophique on a vu
quelques images du chef indien raoni
pour lequel on lance une campagne dans
quelques jours oui en effet ils sont
actuellement pour la plupart ils sont
déjà en confinement et se confirmant
qu'ils ont dû faire dans l'urgence a
fait qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps de se
ravitailler correctement et notamment
les pelles et les produits d'hygiène ou
les produits des produits sanitaires
les médicaments manquent donc en effet
il lance un appel au secours la koica le
chef raoni d'autres bientôt vont aussi
lancer des appels et on a besoin de
mobiliser au niveau international pour
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
délivrance de passeports immunitaire
pourrait favoriser contrairement à ce
qu'on croit la propagation du virus l'
oms affirme qu'il n'y a aucune preuve
pour l'instant que les personnes guéries
du coït 19 même avec des anticorps soit
immunisée l'organisation a lancé par
ailleurs eu une initiative mondiale afin
de coordonner les efforts de recherche
de vaccins dans le monde
et puis aux états unis pour la première
fois depuis trois semaines le nombre de
morts est en baisse 1317 ces dernières
24 heures au total plus de 52000
personnes ont su qu ont succombé aux
cornailles virus depuis le début de
l'épidémie
une crise sanitaire qui frappe de plein
fouet l'économie américaine comme
partout dans le monde
conséquence donald trump a promulgué
hier un plan dette de près de 500
milliards de dollars pour soutenir les
secteurs les plus durement touchés un
certain état à eux ont commencé à des
confiné c'est le cas du texas du vermont
ou encore de la géorgie et puis ce 25
mai marque le 75e anniversaire de la
journée de l'elbe à cette occasion les
présidents russe et américain ont signé
une déclaration commune pour rendre
hommage à ce que l'on appelle l'esprit
des lgv il symbolise l'amitié entre les
deux nations quel que soit l'âge en date
politiques des pays le 25 avril 1945 des
troupes soviétiques et américaines se
sont serrés la main sur un pont
endommagé au dessus de l'elbe elle c'est
dans cette ville allemande que c'est
fait la jonction entre les troupes
russes et américaines et en coupant en
deux l'armée allemande
cette jonction avait alors sonné le glas
du régime nazi
allez on termine par ces très belles
images en direct du théâtre mariinsky à
saint pétersbourg les danseurs russes
qui interprète la belle au bois dormant
sur une musique de piotr tchaïkovski
sans public
bien sûr mais pour le plaisir des
confiné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
oh la la
[Musique]
art
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
tél
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques dans notre pays
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
quelle que soit la qualité expertise
indéniable nos soldats ne peuvent gagner
la guerre pour la raison que je vais
maintenant et que peuvent faire un peu
plus de 5000 militaires français à
l'efficacité certes reconnu sur une zone
aussi vaste même renforcé par cinq mille
soldats promis par les pays vieux zinc
zinc c'est là où les problèmes ont
commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires